so good morning everyone I'm James
Powell as a session chair mentioned I've
been doing PI data for a very long time
I think this is my 2728 PI data
conference I've attended believe this is
the 50-something PI data talk I've given
in the last four years I don't know that
that makes me a Python expert I can tell
you that oh we have a lot of material to
cover so I won't go very deep into my
own introduction other than to tell you
that even though I attend many PI data
events and I help out and organizing all
of these I do this in the capacity of a
volunteer there are a lot of volunteer
opportunities available with mum and
with PI data itself so if you're
interested in running a PI data in your
own city or getting more involved with
open source data science please let me
know or let any of the organizers of
this conference know there's always room
for more volunteers for those of you
who've had the fortune or misfortune of
seeing any of the talks that I've given
previously at PI data event I often give
talks about strange things that you can
do with Python like embed Python
interpreters within themselves or add
features to Python at runtime or patch
your Python so that you can load other
Python interpreters using dynamic linker
tricks and sometimes the subtext of all
of these is you know these are the
lifestyles of the Python experts what
kind of crazy fun that we can have and
so I decided maybe I should give a talk
that might actually be useful to an
audience as opposed to just showing off
some crazy things that you can do and so
one thing that might actually be useful
is to really talk about what it means to
be a Python expert I do a good amount of
doing a couple of different things in my
day job I work on a variety of different
projects I can tell you if you are an
employee at Microsoft and you're
interested in Python something that I
can talk to you about Python Microsoft
is very invested in the future of Python
in more ways than you might even know I
also do some corporate training and in
that corporate training this question of
what's needed to become good at Python
comes up very often so I'm asked to
answer this question for you I can tell
you that what it takes to be effective
in Python it's pretty straightforward to
be effective in Python that requires a
certain understanding of a couple of
core mental models of the language
understanding of some of the things the
language comes with like the built-in
data types and the built-in functions a
little bit of an understanding of what's
available in the standard library this
talk however is focused on the next step
what does it take to be a little bit
better than just effective what does it
take to be good at Python or an expert
of Python now I could spend the next two
hours telling you in very philosophical
terms what that means and I could tell
you why
Python experts do things in one way or
the other we can even go very deeply
into some of the meaning behind the Zen
of Python but instead what I'd like to
show you more specifically is a couple
of what I call perhaps metaphors and
programming in Python it turns out that
as many of you know Python though it
originated is something of kind of a
scripting language is the convenience
language to patch together or to
orchestrate code that was written in C
to write simple scripts has since grown
into a full-fledged
general-purpose programming language and
along the way it's developed its own
ways of thinking about certain core
constructs in programming what I like to
do in the course of this session is show
you four features of Python and the ways
that an expert would think about these
features what I want to show you is not
the syntax of these features the purpose
of this presentation is not a feature
parade it irritates me unending whenever
I see somebody who's writing a book
about advanced Python and the entirety
of the book is chapter one here's a
feature chapter two here's another
feature chapter three here's a third
feature and the entirety of the
discussion of these features is merely
its formal characteristics Oh a
generator has a yield instead of a
return Oh you can't send an on none
value into it just started generating a
lot of fundamental details of how these
features work but very little talk about
how we can conceptualize these features
in the broader sense of what they mean
for modeling core problems and so what
I'd like to do is I'd like to talk about
four of these features that you may have
seen before and a couple of the core
mental models for how you can think
about them and how you can think about
Python as a whole and wrap all of these
together one thing that you'll notice is
in addition to you can probably hear
them a little bit
selphie a little bit sick that's only
going to exaggerate my inability to
remember the syntax or the documentation
for basically anything so you may see me
stumble but part of this presentation is
to see me stumble and to understand that
in cases where you don't understand or
you don't have the documentation
memorized or some of the corner cases
memorized what really is more important
for all of these features is an
understanding of what they are and what
they mean and not so much all of the
implementation details those
implementation details are of course
critically important when you're using a
feature but that's information that you
can look up and refresh when you're
actually in the middle of using that
feature itself before I get started I'd
like to take a small survey of small
informal survey of the audience so how
many of you here are Microsoft employees
almost everyone how many of you are
Microsoft employees that use Python as
part of your Microsoft work how many of
you are just Microsoft employees that
have seen Python used in various areas
of the company but don't really have
direct interaction with it yet how many
of you consider yourself to be pretty
okay at Python I mean if you consider
yourself to be really good at Python a
couple people how many people are
already in the back of the room thinking
I should be in the front of them getting
a talk myself maybe one person maybe one
person in the front okay maybe maybe
we'll have to show you something new
when it comes to those of you who've
seen Python how many of you feel like
you're pretty effective in Python I can
give you a simple problem you can write
some functions maybe even write a class
or two you can solve the problem without
too much sweat
it's that most of you how many of your
complete newbies you're like I have no
idea how you can get started with Python
okay for those of you who are complete
newbies you may struggle a little bit
part of this talk does presume a
baseline of understanding of Python
however I don't think that the core
lessons that you'll pick up here our
lessons which will be totally lost on
you there are a couple of core lessons
which even those of you who are somewhat
effective in Python already may yet have
internalized and we might we might have
a little bit of time to repeat this what
I want to start with
I'll start with something really really
really basic and I'm going to start a
little bit more basic than what I plan
to just because I thought the audience
might be a little bit more advanced than
that
so what I'll talk about at the very
beginning is something that we might
call the data model now what you'll see
is I have all of the materials for this
prepared and memorize in my brain and
unfortunately my brain is getting older
and older as time goes on and so I've
already forgotten exactly what I want to
talk about and so you'll see a little
bit of roughness here but part of the
purpose of this presentation is to
present you with just the information
that matters without a lot of the
distracting details and so I will
actually rewrite all of my notes for
this as we go going to be a little bit
rough but hopefully it will be an
opportunity for us to focus just on what
really matters and for us to put aside a
lot of the associated implementation
details and things which frankly it
matters when you care about them but
it's not part of that core lesson of
understanding Python I want to start off
with something very simple and you can
see I created a directory called data
model and I'll just create a simple file
here I want to create a class and we're
going to do all of this everything in
this course will be or everything in
this session will be in Python 3 6 it'll
be in Python 3 6 just for my own
convenience just so that I don't have to
worry about all the details that might
differ between Python 2 and Python 3
there's no particular reason why I
choose Python 3 versus Python 2 for the
purposes of what I'm going to show you
other than it's the Python that I happen
to use and it's the Python that happens
to be there's some political reasons
behind why python 2 or 3 but even
skipping that it's just for my own
convenience just to simplify things so
let's start with something very simple I
have some class I want to do some kind
of mathematical operation I have some
piece of software I write and I have
some class here that represents a
polynomial some simple you know linear
polynomial with various coefficients and
I want to represent it as a Python
object and so I start with some code
that looks like this right class
polynomial doesn't have anything
interesting and I can create
polynomials very simply
right and I might say p1 has
coefficients one two and three right so
this would be x squared plus 2x plus 3
and p2 has coefficients three four and
three so this would be 3x squared whoops
plus 4x plus 3 okay and I want to be
able to do some simple things that we
did in math class with these I want to
be able to add them I want to be able to
subtract them I want to be able to you
know figure out some details of them the
very first thing for those of you were
relatively effective Python programmers
if you're going to look at this you're
going to say why on earth did you write
that in four lines when you could've
written it in two line why did I write
this in four lines here when I could
have written it in two months
how would I compact my code here so
instead of constructing my two
polynomials and then initializing the
coefficients I could initialize them all
together what would I do
we're trying to get you to give me a
little bit of feedback here so what
would I do what am I missing here my
class has nothing in its body what it's
what is it missing to allow me to do
this little bit more comedian a little
bit louder for me I needed an it method
and so the very first thing when some of
you look at this as you say hold on
you're wasting our time here you
probably want to have internet method
that looks something like this so you
can write these lines much more hoarsely
and you don't have to have four lines
when two lines would do
right so now we're happy
what's
so now we're happy now if I rub my coat
and I'll split my screen shrink this a
little bit and I'll maybe print out
actually I'll do this so I'll run my
code and I have P 1 and P 2 and then
somebody else looks at them says oh my
goodness print it out to the screen that
looks so ugly what am I missing here let
me see another method what am I missing
I'm missing a method that corresponds to
what happens when I call this function
at the top level repper to figure out
the representation of my Python object
yes or no yes so what method do i
implement up here I have some method
called rep work right so I have some
method here that returns a string that
gives me the information gives me a
printable representation of this class
to the screen and so I'll make this very
easy like that and so I'll run my code
again and we'll see how there we go
those are two polynomials pretty
straightforward and we could write we
could make this print out a little bit
prettier we could see the x squared the
X and the constant term if you wanted to
but you can see this is a lot easier
than just seeing the name of the class
and it's memory location and we can
continue down this exercise because the
next thing I want to be able to do is I
want to be able to add these together
and when I add them together nothing
happens Python gives me an error
unsupported operand types 4 plus
polynomial polynomial but that doesn't
make any sense I know I can add
polynomials I did it all the time when I
was in high school how do I tell Python
how to add polynomials I have another
method called add and in my add method I
might return a brand-new polynomial
where I just give it
all of the coasts there of course ride
just zip together and add each of the
individual items so when I run that in
my script here p1 plus p2 it gives me a
polynomial with 4x squared plus 6x plus
6 now what's the pattern that we see
evolving here for those of you who are
off the top of your head you didn't you
didn't remember which of the underscore
functions are for those of you who
haven't ever seen these underscore
functions before you've begun to see
some pattern and what is that pattern I
have some behavior that I want to
implement and I write some underscore
function some function that begins with
200 scores and ends with two underscores
and for those of you who are Python
programmers already you might be
familiar with these underscore functions
you might call them dunder methods or
double underscore methods or if you find
that word abhorrent as I do you might
call it by a different name data model
methods and you might say it's
absolutely absurd thing to call this
data model methods that's so many more
syllables than dunder methods but
there's a reason I call them data model
methods which is I don't think I have
internet access but maybe I do oh I do
if you google for data model and python
the very first or second link depending
on whether you use Bing Google or
DuckDuckGo will be a piece of
documentation here that tells you all of
these methods and what they do but the
pattern is a little bit more interesting
than that it's more than just having all
of these methods on a single piece of
documentation it is that whenever we
want to implement some behavior of
Python we want to tell Python for this
arbitrary object do this behavior give
me something that is a principle
representation for this object perform
some notion of addition for this object
we always see this common pattern and
the pattern is as follows there is a
top-level function or some top-level
syntax
and there's a corresponding underscore
function the exact arguments that
underscore function takes will be
determined by whatever you find on this
documentation page here the name the
default names of the arguments you can
pick up off this documentation here so
for ad I called it self another that's
just the conventional names for this the
what each of these actually do you can
read from the documentation but there's
something more fundamental here there's
a pattern when I want to add two objects
I implement ad when I want to initialize
an object I implement in it when I want
to tell Python what to do when you call
repper on an object I implement wrapper
we know in Python there's a function
called Len it gives you some notion of
the size of an object what would it make
sense for the size of a polynomial to be
what what like that notion be any
thoughts the degree right the highest
degree so we want to implement this
notion of size on this polynomial how do
we actually implement it what's the name
of the underscore function we have to
implement the one hint is there's
usually a very close correspondence here
so what would it be here Len if we
wanted the exact arguments that any of
the caveats for how this needs to be
implemented with a look at documentation
there isn't anything special in the case
of Len and we just return something like
land of coefficients so this will tell
us the size of the polynomial in terms
of its degree and you can see these are
both degree three polynomial the pattern
that we see is as follows the Python
data model is a means by which you can
implement protocols those protocols have
some abstract meaning depending on the
object itself in the case of a
polynomial to add them means whatever
that meant a math class in the case of a
polynomial to find its size means
whatever that would make sense for the
case of mesfet so it may make sense for
us
know what decides this polynomial is in
terms of its highest degree to get its
representation its principle
representation has meaning that's given
to us by the documentation the
representation of any Python object is
typically whatever string we'd have to
type at the consult to create another
instance of that same object and so on
in each case this protocol exists there
is some underscore method that
implements that protocol there is some
top-level function like Len or repper or
some top-level syntax like the plus sign
or the multiplication sign that allows
us to invoke that protocol and it all
fits together in this hole we can think
of this as a protocol in the sense that
like many protocols when we implement
something like Len we do that by
delegating back to the protocol itself
so notice Len is implemented in terms of
lead being called on a constituent
object ad is implemented by adding up
some components namely the coefficients
repper is implemented by calling wrapper
on some component we see this is a very
common pattern in the Python data model
every time we want to implement some
custom behavior on a Python object we do
it by implementing an underscore
function which ties to some top-level
syntax or some top-level function and we
implemented in terms of that thing
itself so for example if we have some
top-level syntax parentheses that coming
after the name of an object and we might
call that the call protocol we'd
implement it by implementing the
function called call we could look at
the documentation to see any caveats or
any special things we have to keep in
mind when we implement that in the case
of a polynomial this may not make a lot
of sense perhaps to call it means
something different maybe if we want to
have some really horrible syntax where
we say p1 p2 means multiplication we
could do that I can't think of anything
more ptosis than that but perhaps that's
what we what we want but in any case we
may implement this in terms of calling
something else
this is one of the core patterns that we
see a Python this is probably one of the
very first patterns that you'd see as a
novice Python programmer in fact when
you look at object orientation of Python
there are three core patterns that you
have to understand to really understand
object orientation Python this is one of
them the protocol view of Python the
second one is the built-in inheritance
protocol and how it works where you go
on a Python object to look for things
and the third one is some caveats around
how object orientation of Python works
that's where I wanted to start off with
and for those of you who are just kind
of on that level of being effective in
Python these are the kind of patterns
that I would encourage you to look out
for as you learn Python
I want to go much deeper than this and I
want to jump into a very tricky metaphor
using a feature which you may have heard
of and you may have been warned against
something you may have seen kind of
along the margins when you're using some
library if you do anything with web
programming and you use Django you may
have seen this in the ORM or you may
have heard people whispering about this
one feature and I want to bring up this
feature for you I want to show you that
it has a very clear and concise meaning
just to illustrate how powerful these
mental models are for understanding
Python itself and for driving expertise
so let's shelve this for a second let's
show this idea of Python having a
protocol orientated data model and let's
look into a new feature I'll create a
new directory called meta classes and
we'll talk about meta classes for a bit
now the gist of this act this tutorial
is actually leading you towards three
features which are far more common I'm
for more interesting the meta classes
namely decorators generators and context
managers there is a reason I want to
start you off with medical axis it's a
feature that everybody is warned against
using they're told it's magical it makes
no sense it's totally the most
complicated thing in the world when in
reality it is the case of a feature
where if you understand what the feature
is really about it is very clear and
very obvious for why and when you use it
and you can it's something that you can
kind of shelve away in your mind as oh
this feature does this this is why I
want to use it I don't need to use it
all the time so let me show you what a
meta class or what meta classes are
really about and I'll show this to you
for an example now here's an opportunity
for you to try something because I think
you'll really appreciate this example if
you try let me do this in a different
way I've read up P Y so I have two files
here I want you to actually try this I
want you to remember I want you to
pretend that there are two groups
working on some one piece of software
one group is a core infrastructure group
and they write library code and the
other group is a developer group and
they write user code the developer group
takes the library code somebody else
wrote and they use that library code to
accomplish actual business objectives
the core infrastructure group gets paid
a lot of money to accomplish no actual
business objectives but to provide
library software that the rest of us can
use isn't that the story of tech
companies which which team would you
rather work on nobody has any opinion
whatsoever I'd rather work on the user
team because I think that's where some
of the more exciting work is and you're
a lot closer where the money is actually
being made so that can't hurt but some
people like to be on the core
infrastructure team because they think
that the technical problems are often
much more interesting than some
particular business units problem around
not getting data in the right format or
who knows well let's say that this
library provides classes and these
classes are expected to be subclassed
in the user code so I'll create a class
here called base and I'll create a class
here called derived that derives from
base
okay I've got five lines of code on the
screen this is a basic pattern we see
this pattern all over the place somebody
writes some class in library code and
somebody else has to use it I'm going to
add two things one function on each side
and then pose a question to you
let's pretend you exist on the
right-hand side of the screen you write
user code
you cannot write or alter or modify or
any way and touch the code on the
left-hand side of the screen you can use
it but you can't change its library code
you don't have source code access to it
even if you did this is being deployed
in some environment where any local
changes you made wouldn't be preserved
maybe in the deployment environment this
is pulled down from NuGet or somewhere
else so you have no way to change the
code on the left-hand side of the screen
your only control is code that you can
write on the right hand side of the
screen where could the code on the
right-hand side of the screen break very
simply where could this function break
if there is no foo method exactly what
can you do in your code to make sure
that at least at the very minimum if the
person who writes the library code
removes that foo method your code fails
not at runtime but at any point earlier
than runtime one very simple thing you
could do is you could write a test that
just calls bar on your derives class
very simple thing and make sure you run
your tests before you deploy and you'll
see the code fail sometime before it
hits the runtime production of art
that's one thing you can do anything
simpler you can think of take a minute
and just try and think is there anything
simpler you could add to this code to
just make sure that this code has the
ability to fail before it hits the run
time production environment doesn't have
to there's no there's not really that
same concept of compile time and Python
as there is another languages but
anything you can think of where you
could just save yourself a little bit of
effort if those core infrastructure
meatheads accidentally screwed something
up and keep you going you know I was I
was on a team I I often worked in a
vendor capacity working on very small
very narrowly defined projects I was in
a situation on Monday
err there was a sev one issue and I was
the only person on the team that was
thought to be involved with it who was
online somebody messaged me and asked me
can you help me with that said one issue
I told him I have no idea I work on one
tiny very small Python specific very
narrow area but apparently I was the
only one between between the manager and
the top of the company itself was online
so I was sitting there trying to sell
trying to tell people sorry I don't know
anything I'm hopeless let's see if we
can avoid those kind of issues let's see
if we can avoid there's anything we
could add to our code so that you don't
have to message me and hear me complain
to you that I don't know anything and
then you see how much I billed per hour
you're like well why are we paying you
so much we don't know what to think what
could you do any thoughts I'll give you
something really easy real easy
oops
what is the student
what's happening here here I check to
see that that method exists if the
method doesn't exist
I assert the code will fail so all I
have to do is make sure all of my
modules can be imported which does not
require a runtime environment I just
import everything if for some reason
they broke this this method here they
gave it a different name they call it
food instead I would see this code fail
before this class is never defined and I
get exactly what I wanted I have some
early warning that this had broken what
we can see in general is that what I'm
trying to do here is enforce a
constraint I'm having the user level and
force some constraints on the library
level in other words the derived class
is enforcing constraint on the base
class the drive class is saying hey the
base class has to have these
characteristics in order for me to run
and be happy and if it doesn't have
these characteristics in this particular
case if it doesn't have this method
implemented I'm going to fail loudly and
I won't run so that's pretty
straightforward
actually that was
that was pretty straightforward it turns
out there's quite a few different ways
we can do this
this little approach is very simple very
straightforward but let's flip the
script a little bit let's say instead we
have a case that looks like this
let's say now you're the core
infrastructure writer and you have to
deal with those meatheads in the
business unit actually using your code
and abusing your code and misusing your
code I have no idea what they're doing
and you write your base class under the
assumption that some responsible
developer in the business unit will go
and implement this bar method because if
they don't everything falls apart now in
this example you exist on the left-hand
side of the screen not on the right-hand
side of the screen you have no ability
to change the code on the right-hand
side of the screen even though you may
be higher up in the technical
organization you have no idea where this
right-hand user code even sits your only
ability is to put out library code for
people to consume you have no idea who's
even using your code you will even if
you could see their code you might not
be able to fix it let's ask a separate
question but a very similar question to
what we had before sitting on the left
hand side of the screen how do you make
sure that the user on the right-hand
side of the screen doesn't screw up how
do you make sure that in this case that
bar method is in fact implemented
because if it's not your code breaks and
they're going to blame you they're going
to call this foo method they're going to
see in the trace back that foo method is
in your file and they're going to blame
you for getting this wrong so how do you
work the other way how do you make sure
they don't screw up we can't do the same
thing we can't say assert has ADD or
derived bar this doesn't make sense on
the left-hand side of the screen we have
to move that to the right-hand side of
the screen we're not allowed to touch
the code on the right-hand side of the
screen so what do we do
any thoughts turns out there are about
three common answers to this one of them
is metaclasses there's two other answers
any thoughts where do we put the
try-catch we could do try here that
would be fine except this will only
occur at runtime so if we try catch here
it's not really any different than just
running this function and seeing the
error will still only see the error at
runtime we won't be able to catch it
before that code his production on July
3rd and they're calling me up to ask me
to help out and like I have no clue
about they're like you're on a team
that's that's involved with as your
security and I'll say I have no clue
anything about Asian security true story
really happens what can we do well if we
think about that very first example we
can see that our data model example
actually goes much deeper than just that
and the reason that we could call Python
a protocol orientated language is not
just because the Python data model the
object model is protocol orientated but
that the entire Python language itself
has a notion of hooks and protocols and
safety valves within it I want to show
you something kind of interesting one
thing that a lot of people who come to
Python from other languages don't
realize is that python is a much simpler
language than you might appreciate for
those of you who are originally C++ or
Java programmers you have a mental model
of your head in your head for how
programming languages like those work
and you have that mental model split
between some compiled time steps and
some run time steps and in that compile
time step there's an enormous amount of
complexity if you look at all the
different optimizations that the visual
studio compiler can perform on code
there's an enormous amount of complexity
there Python it turns out is a much much
simpler language Python code runs from
top to bottom linearly and almost
everything that you see in Python
almost every statement that you see in
Python with the exception
of two of them are actually executable
runtime code in C++ or Java a class
statement is not executable code in C++
it definitely is an executable code in
C++ a class statement just says here's a
bucket of bits here's how you name
portions of that bucket of bits in
Python a class statement is actually
runtime executable code what does that
mean well let's take a look what that
means is that in Python I could do
something like this define a class in a
loop 10 times in a row totally the most
useless thing I could ever do has no
effect whatsoever but I can stick for
loops outside of class bodies and
redefine classes if I want has no use
but it's it's meaningful in Python
I can do the same thing the other way
create a bar method under this foo
object ten times only one of them will
survive all the last one will call all
the previous ones but Python accepts
this as syntax because this class
statement is fundamentally executable
code now I told you and the direction
where we started this was talking about
Python as a protocol orientated language
let's see something kind of interesting
I'm just going to create a function and
I only need this for wrapping purposes
let me create my base class inside some
function and let me use a function in a
module in the Python standard library
called dis dis stands for disassemble
let's disassemble this and see what
actually happens in the Python bytecode
what we see is something kind of
interesting we see that there's this
thing in the Python bytecode called load
build class so it's actual executable
runtime instruction in the Python
interpreter for creating a class well
hold on a second in the very first
example I showed you I said there
typically tends to be in Python some
correspondence between some top level
syntax or function and some underscore
method that implements that syntax or
function there happens to be some top
level mechanism here it's not explicitly
syntax is not explicitly a function for
building a class it turns out in Python
there is a hook there is an underscore
function that allows you to hook into
and to do things with the process of
building class and I bet you can guess
what it's called because just like the
correspondence between repper and double
underscore repre Len and double
underscore Len adding and double
underscore add the same thing here
there's a function of Python called
Bill's class it sits on a module called
the built-ins
so if I equals IBC so if I define a
function here called will do like this
if I do this I'll capture the original
build class I'll write my own build
class I'll import from the built-ins and
I'll swap them out here I can patch into
what Python actually does when it
creates classes and I won't do anything
interesting in here I'll just print out
all the arguments they're passed
okay and so let's run our Python script
one more time Python - I user duck py
whoops
and you can see here's the class that
was created in fact you could even see I
caught another class that was being
built I was probably being built
somewhere in the interactive interpreter
itself but the most important one that
you can see is I actually can catch can
actually catch the building of this
class you can see there's some
interesting things that I'm passed and
pass the name of the class and past its
bases and I passed a function then pass
no other arguments well what I can do
now that I can see the class time
building is I could hook into this and I
could do something with it right I could
add my assert here I could say if the
actual arguments for this are this is
where I can't remember them the function
the name and the basis function the name
and the basis and I could say if the
base actually the base if the base is
equal to this base here or if it's
actually this actual base object
I could check at the bar math is defined
and when I run this you can see
let's pass in any kW here as well
which arduous would take one to help the
third one is optional because not
everything has to have a base class and
[Applause]
and who cares we this is a little this
one you can see I struggle with this one
a little bit because we never we don't
typically do this we say if space is not
none
okay there we go you can see we were
able to have a little place where we
could check if that bar method was
defined this isn't typically what we do
but it's to show you this idea of Python
being a protocol orientated language is
actually quite a common pattern and
quite a fundamental piece of Python
almost everything that a Python language
does in an execution context like
building classes creating functions
importing modules you can find a way to
hook into that once you can find a way
to hook into that you can start doing
things that you want to do like check is
my user code going to break from the
perspective the library author now the
reason that I struggle with writing this
function here it's in part because first
what's really the most important here is
understanding this pattern exists
knowing that there are options for
solving this pattern and also knowing
that this is not the option that you'd
ever use for solving this better build
class is available for you to use but
it's not how people actually solve this
problem there are two fundamental
features in Python that people use to
solve the problem of enforcing
constraints from derived class to base
classes the first one is the metaclass
meta classes are merely
classes that derive from type that have
some special methods on them but you'll
have to read the documentation to
understand all the special methods for
but fundamentally allow you to intercept
the construction of derived types the
method that you care about here is
called new and it takes three or four
arguments basis body and the name basis
in the body
and we'll see where it gives us an
opportunity to actually perform our
check
a patient's body
you can see it got called right here
with our derived class you can see this
last argument for the drive class is the
body of that class it's a dictionary
with all the methods of that class you
can see in it the bar method and so
simply to get the behavior I want I
could simply do assert bar or if not bar
in body raised type error bad user just
like that this is the first answer to
the core question in order to enforce
the constraint the other way around if I
can only touch the code in the left hand
side of the screen and not the
right-hand side of the screen I can't
just have assert lines all over the
place I have to do something
fundamentally different and the thing I
have to do fundamentally different is I
have to find a way to intercept how
classes are constructed of which there
are three common approaches built class
which is the least common approach but
works on the idea that Python is a
protocol based language has the safety
valves and hooks even in things as
fundamental as the construction of any
class second meta classes which are just
the mechanism by which classes are
constructed that's the approach that you
see here and I'll show you the third one
the third one is just a slight variant
on the metaclass approach when people
tell you about meta classes typically
they tell you this is a magical feature
you'll never need to use this feature
it's overly complicated and the reason
that I like to start this this session
with that despite its yes being a very
rare feature feature you'll very rarely
have to use is to show you that every
feature of Python so far has at least
one or two very clear and unambiguous
mental models is applicable to one or
two very clear and unambiguous metaphors
for where it's actually useful in this
case meta classes are how you can make
sure that if you only control the code
on the left-hand side of the screen you
can still enforce constraints on the
code on the right-hand side of the
screen you can enforce constraints down
the class hierarchy from a base class to
a derived class
this is one approach using a metal clasp
that just intercepts the construction of
the clasp and the second is even easier
it turns out that in Python meta classes
are have a bad reputation because even
those people who understand where
they're useful see that meta classes
have a lot of complexity to them part of
what I haven't told you at all is any of
the syntax of the meta class or any of
the arguments they take or any of the
details for how the class hierarchy fits
together because all of that doesn't
really matter when you need to know that
information
you'll go look up and find that
information but unless you know why you
want to use the metaclass in the first
place it doesn't matter how many details
of the feature you need to know once you
understand where and why you need to use
the feature then the rest of it are just
details you look up when you start
looking up those details you'll see that
in many of the features I show you the
story isn't that easy
there's always caveat there's always
catches and one of the catches is this
metaclass feature is very clumsy to use
and so in Python 36 a new feature was
used or a new feature was added called
an it subclass and in its subclass I
think it goes here
it just gives you a method that allows
you to hook into when a subclass of some
class is being initialized and that's it
and I think it goes I think it goes here
let's find out if Brett were here you
could tell you exactly what this
let's remove the metaclass for now
[Music]
I will do one thing if will be that
there
okay so yes it got called the right
place and then it's a PLAs okay yeah so
this gets called with the self so the
other approach we do is as follows
this is being called on that and with
the knit subclass we have other hooks
for figuring out
this one would come in in its subquest
have to remember what arguments it takes
but you can look into it really frankly
it does not matter that much so this is
my simple story about metaclasses
metaclass is our feature that we're
often told that are an expert-level
feature you're not supposed to ever use
them you should shy away from them you
should cover your eyes before you read
code that includes metaclasses and it
simply isn't that it simply is that for
all of these advanced features there's
usually one or two very clear metaphors
to understand what that features all
about and once you understand what that
features all about there's a lot of
details you need to read through and
documentation that's the approach I want
to take for the remaining three features
I want to show you the next feature is a
very simple feature called decorators
I'm sure some of you already see in this
feature
but I want to show you kind of where
this feature comes from it's a very
simple and very boring feature indeed
and you've probably seen this feature
before it's this little act that shows
up on top of some function definition
this little app with a dotted name so
you see something like a dot B dot C and
for those of you who are very familiar
with this feature you might wonder why
you can't do this or why there are
limitations to what you can put in a
decorator line the answer for it is a
really stupid answer there is no good
reason but there is a limitation for
those of you haven't seen this feature
before I want to show you something
about Python something very cool and
very fundamental about Python I told you
when we talked about metaclasses that
python is a live language there is no
separate step that turns function
definitions into bags of a set bits
tagged and some elf binary or some PE
binary somewhere that a function
definition is actually a live thing it
actually runs at runtime there's
actually executable code associated with
this def F okay so let me show you that
in practice
here's a function called add that adds
two values okay let me create a little
separation down here and let me run that
and here I have my function add and I
can add two values now notice the first
thing I did in my terminal is I looked
at the function itself and I got a
return value you can see that the Python
interpreter can actually tell me where
physically a memory this function exists
and in fact this add function is an
object and I can ask it all sorts of
things like what's your name what's your
module where you were defined I can ask
it let's give that a default value there
and run this again I can say add what
are your defaults and it can tell me
what default values it had I can say
what's your code like what code do you
can do you contain this is actually the
byte codes for this add function and you
can see them right here I could ask it
things like how many local variables do
you have that's your name
there's one more that's interesting for
our names I can ask you what variable
names do you do interact with one of the
variable names of your signature x and y
and do all sorts of things that interact
live with this function well it's
interesting that this function itself is
a runtime object we kind of see this or
you might be familiar with this for C or
C++ programmers in C and C++ we can have
function pointers but they're really
just determined by the compiler they're
just memory addresses the compiler knows
for where it put the bag of bits that
represents that function sits in Java
for a Java programmer or a c-sharp
programmer we might be familiar with
runtime classes and functions under
those runtime classes and Python it's
closer to the latter but much simpler
than that
every Python structure that you interact
with whether it's an object or a
function or a generator has some runtime
life has some runtime existence you can
see it in memory you can ask it
questions like what module UI were you
defined in you can even ask it very
useful questions like if you use the
inspect module you can say what's your
source code and I'll tell you the source
code right back out
so you can see you can ask the function
to give it source but it'll give you a
source code right back you can ask it
what file are you in and it'll tell you
what file is to find it you can ask it
what mods are defined in or I think get
line you can get get it ask what line
number it was defined on get acid all
sorts of important questions well
there's something interesting that you
can also do let's say that I have some
code here that calls my add function
maybe it's part of some testing code or
maybe it's some code part of some
application
let's give it one more example so you
can see I'll add both numbers and also
add strings okay
simple enough let's say that I want to
change my code very slightly let's say
for some reason this add function isn't
quite doing what I want or maybe it's
doing what I want but I need to do
something like time how long it takes to
run because for some reason some of
these are much slower than other things
it takes a lot of time to run I want to
time it and so what are my options well
I know in the time module there is a
time function so I know I can say time
and I can get the time right now and you
do that again I can subtract them and
figure out how many seconds it took and
so how would I time these I'd say before
equals time after equals time print time
taken after - before like this and now I
could kind of profile my code except
this kind of sucks because every time I
do this I need to add this in n places
throughout my code after a turn all
sorts of places throughout my code
there's something missing here there's
something wrong here when we look at
this example and we think about
decorators in the context of the problem
we're trying to solve here we see
another core and important pattern in
Python the Python developers really
don't want you to be here today because
it's the 5th of July and they'd rather
you be home with your family spending
time with them I'm very happy that
you're here today in this session and I
hope you're enjoying yourself so far
but what I mean by saying the Python
core developers don't want you to be
here is this given the option between
writing and absolutely complete forward
compatible absolutely perfect solution
to a given problem and writing the
simplest stupidest quickest thing that
gets the job done the core developers or
the Python language would rather that
you write the simplest stupidest
quickest thing to get the job done and
go home and spend the rest of the day
with your family and the reason that you
know that that's true is that when you
look throughout the Python programming
language there are a number of examples
of cases where you can write the simple
and stupidest thing to get the job done
and when the task at hand becomes harder
or more complex or the requirements
change you can change your code in a
very simple fashion to linearly extend
its functionality without having to
rewrite everything from scratch this is
a fundamental difference between writing
code and Python and writing code in a
language like C++ in C++ there is a lot
of upfront design that you need to do in
order to be effective and if you make a
mistake and something in your upfront
design in C++ you're going to be
rewriting a lot of code down the line
whereas in Python we'll see a number of
different features are orientated around
how do we write the simplest thing today
and then when the problem gets a little
bit harder we have an avenue for making
our code a little bit more complex here
we can see a bad example of that because
in the case where I want the code to be
a little bit more complex I wanted to
capture the timings for how long this
function took in addition to the
function output I've made my code
substantially more complex I've added a
lot of garbage and I've rewritten a lot
of stuff and you can think the ratio of
library code here to user code here it's
usually a lot more user code than
library code the whole point of writing
library code in the first place and so
to have
three times to have to have to add code
in three different places instead of one
place makes for something pretty pretty
gnarly so the first thing that you might
say as well I could add that code in
just one place I could say something
like this capture my return value and do
the time before and the time after print
it out here
like that and you this would be
definitely better than before definitely
better than before I've added coded one
place instead of three places but if my
library looked like this and maybe I had
examples my life my library looked like
that then I'm still really not in the
best situation because I have to add all
this tracking code to two places so it's
got to be a better way and in fact my
library could still be very big and so
it still means I have to write a lot of
code and rewrite a lot of code so it
must be a better way now remember what I
tell you I told you that the pipe that
Python programming language is a live
language that everything has some
runtime representation so both this add
function and this sub function have
runtime representations the sub doesn't
work on strings so both add and sub are
functions what can I do well maybe I
could write my own function called time
right or timer and I take a function and
I take the X and the y arguments and I
apply this function like that
so blowing up right and I do the timing
before and I do the timing after and I
print the elapsed time here
and I returned the return value okay now
I would just have to change these lines
of code slightly I have to change that
from a parenthesis to a comma and so on
as long as I could account for the
default back I have to change each one
of these lines as follows it's a little
bit better not that much better but a
little bit better I'll change the first
three and we'll see it at work so you
can see from time to time let's make
this a little bit smaller so it all fits
on the screen at the same time and you
can see these three more times the rest
part that's still not that much better
I can still do better well remember that
everything happens live in the Python
programming language so couldn't I just
create a new function here couldn't I
define a new function here that takes
two arguments like this and in this
function do the timing call the function
that was passed in and return this
function here and you can see this here
is a wrapper that calls the function
that was passed in and wraps it with
some time behavior before and after and
printing something out when I do that I
can define functions at runtime I can
define functions anywhere and then
instead of all this nasty that's
changing all this user code
I could just say ad equals timer of ad
and sub equals timer of sub and you can
see it added that behavior across
everything and you can see what I do
that what I'm doing is I'm taking one
function I'm wrapping with some behavior
I'm taking one aspect or one piece of
code or common functionality and I'm
wrapping a bunch of different functions
in a really simple fashion and all I'm
doing is I'm creating a new function
that takes the original function and
wraps it with a little bit of behavior
before and after and that's it and it
turns out that python wants to make this
a little bit easier for you because this
pattern of something equals call a
function on that original thing that
exists and that's what a decorator is in
python a decorator is merely syntax
that's equivalent to the line that says
this sub equals timer of sub that's all
it is it's syntax that then fits into
the ability to dynamically construct a
function to wrap this behavior so this
is what our final example would look
like we would have started with code
that looked like this we would have had
to add only the timer code and then to
decorators and we be able to very easily
slip in this extra functionality we want
without having to rewrite all this user
code ourselves that's the core of what a
decorator in Python is at its core it is
very simple syntax to just allow you to
write an ugly pattern sub equals timer
of sub and a slightly nicer way and a
slightly nicer place at the top but
fundamentally it's about allowing you to
take this wrapping behavior for
functions and to wrap wide swathes of
functions in one fashion without having
to rewrite a lot of user code or having
to even perform a lot of turn on your
library code that's what a decorators go
ahead
so one of the problems here I think
you're identifying here I hard-coded the
parameters right and I even hard-coded
the default the real answer is this is
where we use starts and start start
quarks
now this decorator works on any function
that takes any arbitrary set of
positional and keyword parameters and
just forwards the one and so now this
will work to wrap any function with any
set of defaults in any fashion this is
part of why starts and starts our quarks
are so powerful they're there for
arbitrary to write functions that can
take any arbitrary parameter spec and
forward it on in any fashion
because that was at the core of what
you're asking
James
[Music]
so you want to do something an N number
of times that's easy enough to so what
you want to do so say you want to have
the ad just run three times in a row and
you want to have the sub run twice in a
row what you do we'll take off the timer
decorator so we want to have some
function that runs n times right we have
our wrapper function in the middle that
takes any arguments here and here and
the question is how do we identify how
many times we're going to add one more
level to this what we'll say it's we'll
say that n times gives you a decorator
so let's let's actually let's start this
very simply let's assume that we always
want n times to be twice okay we only
want to run this function twice so I'll
say four I'll just say n equals two here
for da in range of N or V equals
function like that
okay so here's our rapper they'll just
call the function twice capture the
value twice and return it and or torn
our rapper and then we can do we can
apply this here and here now we won't
see this really happen we won't see we
won't see the results here but if we
wanted to you could you could do this
so you can see it ran ad twice here ad
twice here sub twice there now you want
to generalize this because you don't
want to run it just two times you want
to run at some number of times why can't
we just wrap this another function that
takes the end and just return this like
that right so now this is a function it
takes how many times these are what they
call higher-order decorators really not
that interesting or that important it's
a fairly simplistic extension of the
idea which is if you could return one if
you can have a function that returns a
function then you can have a function
that returns a function where that inner
function then returns another function
ad infinitum going as deep as you want
to solve whatever problem you want there
is a very important core concept that is
hidden in here which is what you might
call the closure object duality it's not
something that we have time to look at
in this session but it is a very
important duality in Python but it's not
one of the topics that we can look at
but just to show you this in practice
you can see this got called twice
this got called five times so you can
write your own end times decorator very
easily as well and the core of it is
just the idea that you start with the
wrapper so this is just a wrapper
function what you're replacing it with
the decorator syntax allows you to do
that replacing very easily and then in
order to get this programmatic behavior
you just add one level a function
outside that constructs the decorator
the decorator then constructs the
wrapper the wrapper and then wraps the
function itself it is rare that you'll
see a decorator deeper than this just
because it's very rare that you have
contacts that there's there's there's
typically not an additional context
where you need to feed information in
that requires you to have decorators
deeper than this so that's a decorator
decorators are probably the least
interesting of all the functions were to
look at or one of the features were to
look at the next feature I want to look
at is called generators
now some of you may already know what a
generator is generators are very
interesting and very powerful feature of
Python they're also a feature that
include where I feel that mental model
is often very limited what people
understand the mental model is often
fairly limited there's more to it than
just what you might call the eagerness
versus laziness divide but let me start
you off with something more fundamental
than even that I told you before that
there is always some top-level syntax or
function and some underscore method that
implements it so I told you if you have
parentheses after something this is
what's called the call protocol so
there's some method call that implements
it I want you to tell me what's the
difference between this and this
what's items to add one and add two
and I'll even create a terminal down
here and I'll add one adds two numbers
and two adds two numbers from the
outside what's the difference between
these two you wouldn't unless you
started peeking inside unless you
started saying what are you add one oh
you're a function what are you add two
so they started peeking on the inside of
your class you wouldn't be able to tell
the difference
functionally there's no way for you to
distinguish between the two in fact add
one behind-the-scenes looks very similar
to add two it's just that
syntactically it's a whole hell of a lot
easier to write so from the perspective
of actually writing the code you're
always going to want our proof you're
always going to want to you know do this
way now there is a fundamental
difference which is if you wanted to
start adding some stateful behavior like
this
right you wanted to add that and clearly
there's one way to do it for add for it
for the adder there's another way to do
it for the function so one way to do it
for the classroom always do it for the
function and this is the app for mention
what I hinted at this object close your
duality so actually a couple of
different approaches you can think of
for how you do this
the core idea here is that fundamentally
there is some very nice syntax and then
some object model that everything kind
of sits in and this is closer to what
the object model itself looks like you
can think that ad 1 is some object that
kind of looks something like this
although we'll remove the statefulness
stuff just so that the two examples are
at parity let's think about this in a
different way let's think about some
function that takes a lot of time to do
something right maybe a function that
goes off and performs that request and
it needs to load data from a database
what would that function look like well
it might have their words the resulting
rows and it might say you know while DB
read rows that a pen something now this
will be a little bit tricky for us to
actually demo so we'll do a couple of
simplifications just to make this code
look you know kind of mimic what
long-running computational code looks
like but without actually having to use
any fancy libraries so let's say what we
have instead is we have some code and it
just sleeps for a half a second every
time it provides a return value and the
return value will just be a number from
0 to 9
let me ask you a question we'll call
this our we'll just call this compute
whoops when I call compute how long does
it take to run
five seconds what if I only care about
the first return value what if I only
care about the first value how long does
it take to run what if I care about the
first three values how long does it take
to run how much memory in terms of if we
if we just make very simple assumptions
how much memory does compute require 10
spaced 10 units of memory 10 integers in
a list right what if I only care about
the first time how much memory disney's
same right what if I care about all the
elements how much memory does it use say
this is what we often mean by eager the
idea that this function irrespective of
what you actually care about in this
computation always takes the exact same
amount of memory and the exact same
amount of time it easily gives you the
entire result and you're sitting there
waiting for the entire result so you can
see it gives me the entire result all at
once
this is undesirable because if this
happens to be not 0.5 seconds but 5
seconds but I have to wait 50 seconds
before I can even start processing the
very first entry and so I'm sitting
there blocked waiting for 50 seconds
when maybe I could process these one by
one also if this is not ten entries but
a million entries maybe I'll need to
care it maybe I only want to look at
them one by one I don't need to have the
whole history of all the entries I'm now
spending gigabytes of memory just so you
can easily give me the entire result set
what I only care to look at them one by
one and the moment I look at one of them
I can throw it away so you can see this
is both wasteful from the perspective of
the time that it takes and wasteful from
the perspective of the amount of memory
it takes let's think of there's a better
way to do this and let's think about
this in terms of our object model
let me rewrite compute as a class
so it doesn't take any arguments I'll
just dump this stuff underneath nothing
very interesting here but more or less
does the exact same thing really no
difference between the two versions so I
haven't gained anything here I haven't
gained anything by seeing into my object
model that said I've kind of seen this
pattern before I've seen this pattern of
I only want one element at a time and
I'm going to get each elements and as I
get each element I'll process it and
maybe throw it away so basic looping
construct the fact I see it even here in
this looping construct here I don't get
the entire list of once I only get each
one individual element of the list and
one thing that we might know is that in
Python we see top-level syntax or
top-level functions has some
corresponding underscore methods that
implement it if I told you that there is
a pattern there's some if I told you
there's some syntax for X and XS and I
told you that this syntax actually looks
like this more or less under the covers
you can probably guess what the
underscore functions we have to
implement would be they had correspond
to these two top-level functions here
and here they'd be in ER and they'd be
next so what that means is we can take a
class in Python we can add an inner and
our next method and suddenly that class
can be iterated over well in the process
of that iteration what could we do well
anything arbitrarily including perform a
long computation so what we could do and
what the inner method actually needs to
return you'll find out when you read the
documentation it's not that important
will just return self the next method
just gives you each next method that you
iterate over well instead of putting the
computation in this Igor call method
what if I did this what if I have the
inter method say the last number I
looked at with zero and I do this itself
that last plus equals one if self
stopped last is greater than and will
limit this loop back to ten just to keep
our live sane it's greater than ten
raise the operation
otherwise we sleep for 0.5 seconds and
we return self dot last and we'll
actually do this will be slightly
different so we'll do it like this
okay
so there this will give us the same
thing so now slightly different order
but you can see now our next method
computes what was the last value we
looked at captures it the increments the
last value we looked at if there's too
many it raises a stop iteration we won't
worry about what that means just yet
it'll sleep corresponding to our
long-running computation and or return
the value now notice something different
between this compute method and this
next method this compute method returned
a list of all the values this next
method returned a single value and the
way that you'd use it is as follows
you just put it out you loop over and
print it out and we'll actually see that
here in practice you can see it's
computing each value one at a time and
in this loop here you can do something
you want with it I print it out it still
takes 50 seconds in total to print out
the whole thing but you only pay for or
still takes five seconds of total to
print out the whole thing but you only
have to pay for one unit of computation
before you can start using that value
and it no longer requires 10 units of
memory because there's no storage
anymore notice here there's no storage
and here there's no list there's no
storage well this really looks ugly and
this is really hard to read just like
this looks really ugly and this is
really hard to read and there's a much
simpler way to write it a much simpler
formal expression for how to write
functions there's a much simpler way to
write a function that operates in this
fashion and that's what the generator
syntax is a generator syntax is merely
something that looks like this
and all this means is this thing here
compute is something that can be
iterated over each time you iterate over
it this is the value that it will yield
the stop iteration naturally happens
because if you try and iterate over this
too many times
there'll be nothing left to yield
because you'll have fallen off the end
of this block here if state is
maintained internally it's just a
function that kind of doesn't really
return eagerly you'd never want to write
this formulation this is just such a
pain in the butt you'd instead want to
take the original function formulation
and write it in its generator
formulation when you look at the
function formulation the generator
formulation you squint your eyes you can
see all the same pieces in the same
places except in one of them you have
storage and you have eagerly eager
computation of the entire result set and
then the other one you have no storage
and you're simply returning values as
you see them this is the core concept
behind the generator and the core mental
model behind the generator that instead
of eagerly computing values you give
them to the user as they ask but there
is another similarly important and
critical core concept to how generators
work beyond just us and that's what I
want to show you leading up into our
last example we have all seen API to
look like this run this first
we've all seen api's that look like this
which have methods that indicate the
order which you have to run functions if
you don't run this first first
everything blows up if you don't run
this last last everything blows up and
in the documentation they tell you
please run this method then this method
then this method because if you do it in
any other order all hell breaks loose
unfortunately this API is kind of lying
to you because nothing stops you from
being a dunderhead so i don't like to
work dunder and doing this
nothing physically stops you from
putting these in the wrong order other
than that you fail to read the
documentation and you'll see a break
well one interesting thing about the
generator formulation is that if you
look at the generator formulation you
can see it performs some computation
then not only does it yield the result
back but it also yields control back to
the caller you can see here in this
formulation lower case this I perform
one computation one long-running
computation modeled by this sleep and
then I give the value back to the user
to do something with and then they ask
the next computation give it back to the
user to do something with so I'm kind of
interleaving the user code in the
library code in the ego formulation the
library code ran to completion gave the
entire result set back to the user then
the user did whatever they want with it
in the generator formulation I have a
little bit of library code run a little
bit of user code run a little bit of
library code run over the user code run
and I interleave them this is the actual
core conceptualization behind what the
generators are built upon the idea of
co-routines subroutines we can think of
as any piece of executable code that
runs from some starting point to some
ending point to completion they have
they have one single entry way in the
Hat sorry they have one single entry
point they have one single exit point
and that's it they run they're done if
you look at how user code and library
code interact if the subroutine is in
library code it runs the completion and
then the user code has to pickup for the
generator or the co-routine you enter
the generator and as you asked for
values the generator runs but you can
have this nice interleaving where some
user user code runs as the generator for
a value the generator runs it's code
yields back to the user code the user
code does River at once goes back to the
generator astronaut of alyou and so on
so this interleaving of the two pieces
of your code the user code in the
library code here in this API what we
actually have is similarly when we use
this API we'd ideally want to have some
interleaving because we if we could run
all three of these methods all at the
same time
would never provided as three methods if
we didn't have to have some code between
these three calls they would never be
provided it's different calls if they
can all be done at once
we just have one method here called do
it that just calls first second and last
and make sure that we can't screw this
up so the reason that the API gives us
these three pieces split into three
parts is because I specifically intend
us to interleave code they just want to
make sure we interleave code in a fixed
sequencing in a fixed order well let's
think about this if I wrote this as a
generator we could do that interleaving
while maintaining the sequencing and
this I would say is maybe even a more
critical mental model for generators
than this II girlís eager vs lazy
divided the idea that generators are a
mechanism by which you can create code
that can interleave with other code and
also enforce sequencing notice here that
what happens when this generator runs is
it'll run up to this point yield no
value but will yield control back to the
caller then the caller can resume and
the caller can resume in this particular
formulation first second and last will
always run in that order you can't
guarantee the last full run but you
never can guarantee that someone could
pull the plug before that runs but here
if the API are provided in this fashion
you could guarantee that the last method
was never called before the first of the
second method the generator forces that
sequencing on you and it forces that
sequencing on you because the generator
is ultimately a code tune that allows
you that's interleaving between two
types of code user code and library code
let's remember that and we'll go into
the final of the examples we want to
look at the context manager
context managers are a very very simple
metaphor and a common metaphor you see
all over the place if you're a C++ user
you've seen this metaphor before you've
probably called it resource allocation
is initialization something like that if
you're a Java programmer you see in this
metaphor before but I don't know what
you call it in Java I don't know if Java
has a real name or concept for this it's
the idea that there's always some desire
to do some setup and teardown and you
want to combine them if you're a Python
programmer and you've done even very
introductory stuff with Python you've
seen a context manager before and it
looks something like this the most basic
context manager you've seen before you
open some file and the reason use a
context manager here is that there's
some corresponding setup and teardown if
you open the file you got to close the
file this is especially true on Windows
because on Linux file lots are a little
bit less aggressive on Windows if you
don't close the file you might not be
able to delete it later this is
especially true if perhaps this file is
backed by some storage where it's not
necessarily automatically flushed if
there's some IO buffering because
definitely if you open the file on your
right to it you want to make sure those
are flush to disk in case the program
terminates at some point with unflushed
IO buffers you might lose things that
you intended to be written to disk but
fundamentally there is this metaphor
here this idea that we have some set up
action and some teardown action some
initial action and some final action we
want to match them together let me show
you an example of that
it goes beyond files but it can go even
to things like SQLite databases so in
SQL in SQLite we have these these file
back databases the connect method is
actually a context manager itself
so here I connected some database I have
some coarser on that database and let me
just do this and I could do some
statement so I could do something like
create table points X int y int create
so I have some statement to execute a
table maybe insert some things into this
table X Y values 1 1 there we go and
then I have some statement where I could
select for this
there we go
and we could commit this so here we have
just very simple use of a context
manager wrapping some database
operations and what is it's not Kerr dot
to commit we don't need that actually
and what we'll do is we also want to
make sure that we drop our table when
we're done there we go until you can see
the code ran I'll do two selects just so
you can see everything you can see our
code ran now you can see that the idea
of there being some setup and teardown
action it's pretty clear with the
opening and closing of the database
right obviously if you open the database
and we write to it you want to close it
well there's another setup and teardown
action that you might not see here see
if you can spot if we assume that we did
something we want to have some
corresponding action to undo it what's
the what's the pair that you see here
yeah I create a table and I drop a table
now naturally if we were to really
properly do this we probably do in the
transaction the transaction would give
us the right semantics but let's assume
that for SQLite we might not have
transactional support so we have to be
in charge of that pairing that create
and that prop and naturally it's a very
very natural pairing you create
something you drop it you want to make
sure the both of them get done
irrespective of some error pops up in
the middle so how do we actually write
our own context manager and you'll see
that this will bring together everything
we've looked at so far as I told you it
turns out fundamentally in Python there
is always some top-level syntax or some
function and some underscore methods
that implement it if I told you
let's write it like this to X as X if I
told you that behind the scenes this
actually looks like the following
x equals c TX enter try finally
if I told you that and I don't know what
the are there's some arguments that
capacitor I don't care what they are so
if I told you that's what it looks like
you even know exactly what the
underscore methods are they're right in
front of your face right enter an exit
so that's how we write a context manager
we implement enter an exit now here
you're going to see me really fumble
because I don't remember any of the
arguments that capacitor let's try this
so we're going to create a temp table
context manager and we know we need to
implement enter and exit right and this
takes some other arguments I don't
really care what they are and we know
maybe this temp table needs to take you
know just for this thing to work we'll
need to initialize it with a cursor okay
and then the enter just execute this
statement and the exit just execute that
statement except this is self dot cursor
and this is self dot cursor and that's
it we have some enter code into Mexico
and I just move things around to fit it
into the protocol and then the next
thing I do is I just have these over and
I say with temp table curie calls with
that cursor fair enough
there we go
so let's see that in play
seemed to work let's run that again
seemed to work let's run that again
seemed to work if the table weren't
destroyed then I would get an error
there saying table already exists so
clearly the entering the exit being
called I can even show you that more
explicitly this seems really really
uninteresting so where's he going with
this
I wonder see there's the answer the exit
pretty straightforward
now I wonder why I brought this one up
because context managers have such a
clear and unambiguous metaphor behind
them why would I take almost you know a
third or a fourth of our time to talk
about context managers once you see
something kind of interesting here kind
of interesting here can the exit be
called before the enter should it nope
so the enter should always be called
before the exit right what does that
tell you there's some sequencing what
does that suggest to you generator
because we just saw generators or about
sequencing maybe I can improve this
example by using a generator because
here you can see there's an enter and
exit the answer has to be call before
the exit there's some sequencing
necessarily that's the generators are
all about so let's do it like this
let's move this up here let's move this
down up here we'll put a yield in
between the two and here we'll just say
temp table we'll call this context
manager let's say temp table salt cursor
will create an instance of this and then
we'll just do next self dot gen I think
that'll work
and I'm going to turn itself
I wanted to contact manager
we have to do another next in here and
then we have to just do one tiny thing
here that doesn't really matter that
much so there we go we see everything
still work so we'll put our we'll put
our little enter and exit print
statements just to see them still
running enter up here or watch you make
this a little bit better we'll say
created table print drops table just add
our little locking statements in there
just so we can see them in our code
create a table drop table so we can see
how this conceptualization of generators
as sequencing is very useful now this is
not sufficiently general for my purposes
because you can see I kind of hard code
what the generator is so let me just do
this I'll just have it initialize what I
want the generator
what generator I want to use the enter
notice I can I have a callable function
here so what I'll do is I'll just add in
a call here so I can get some arguments
which will be the cursor or maybe the
args and the quarks I just capture those
on the enter I'll call my generator with
the arguments that I was passed and I'll
get my generator instance and I'll
forward it here and here so now I can
say context manager
of temp table I can call the cursor
there and then I have something that'll
work now let's see if that works and
then this has to return itself and then
this should be self kwargs okay there we
go so we can see this still works now
you might wonder why did I go through
all this effort well I want to show you
something kind of interesting this line
here looks really ugly so here why don't
I just do this just move my code around
a little bit take that line here and
I'll just say temp table equals context
manager temp table you can see what I
kind of did was I took my generator and
I wrapped it in some object they just
kind of sit edan the parts of the
generator to the enter in the exit right
that's all I did and now I can just say
with temp table of course circ right
this will kind of mean you probably seen
this like a couple minutes ago never saw
that pattern before I've seen something
like that
anyone seems really useful Python syntax
so you don't have to write that
you take some object that happens to be
a function you pass it to another thing
that gives you something else and that
reminds it anyone seen this tonight
before I can tab back to the panel it's
going to back what is it well what we do
here why would we not write this because
we have a simpler syntax locally right
easier here anybody decorator so you can
see it works without the decorator for
we'd probably just write this like that
right oops still works well it turns out
all this garbage up here we don't have
to write it's already been written for
us it's in a library called context Lib
and it's just a decorator that turns
it's just a decorator that turns a
generator into a context manager and the
only things that we need to make this
work completely is that here in this
example I want to show you something
this is an example that combines three
core features of Python together
generators context managers and
decorators it doesn't requiring that you
know a little bit of the details of how
each of these work but fundamentally
what we can see is what we have here is
three features with very clear
conceptual meaning orthogonal conceptual
meaning where each of those pieces of
conceptual meaning kind of fit together
a context manager is merely some piece
of code that pairs setup and teardown
actions so the teardown action always
occurs if the setup action occurred a
generator is merely some form of syntax
that allows us to do things like enforce
sequencing and interleaving notice the
context manager requires interleaving
because it's set up is interleaved with
the actual action you do in the block
you do the setup then the action in the
block and the teardown at the end there
is that sequencing where the set up the
enter has to be done before the exit
so it makes sense to have a generator
here as well finally we need something
to adapt the generator to this data
model that we looked at at the very
beginning we have these underscore
methods and we have to find some way to
take how the generator works and fit it
into those underscore methods one of the
things we need to do in order to do that
is we need to take this generator object
to wrap it in some fashion that wrapping
is part of the core of how Python works
it's easy to dynamics and construct
functions and have those functions wrap
other functions that's part of the core
language itself it's not really
something that we could even lift the
level of being a feature it really is
core to how Python itself is written
however there does happen to be a
feature called decorators that allows us
a nice convenient syntax for doing that
exactly so what you can see here is an
example of everything except metaclasses
and how they all fit together and how
some of these core pieces of Python fit
together to write what you might
consider to be more nearly expert level
code what I can tell you is that in
Python expert level code is not code
that uses every single feature it's in
fact not code that even uses that many
features of Python it's code that has a
certain clarity to where and when a
feature should be used it's code that
doesn't waste the time of the person
who's writing it because they say to
themselves I have this pattern Python
has this mechanism I fit them together
and everything just seamlessly and and
very smoothly works it's code that
doesn't have a lot of additional
mechanisms associated with it it doesn't
have people creating their own protocols
it doesn't have people creating their
own frameworks where the language itself
provides the core pieces that you need
and you merely have to understand what
those core pieces are what they need and
how to assemble them so over the last 90
minutes I've shown you a couple of
details of how Python itself is designed
and for features that you've probably
heard of that Python is known for for
features that you might associate with
features that are expert with no or at
least a
you go and interview for a Python job
and you say I'm an expert Python
programmer these are four features that
you're going to be asked about more
likely the question here is does anybody
remember any of the syntax they looked
at probably not even I don't remember
and I'm giving the talk and I have cheat
I have notes here I have like a cheat
sheet
the real answer here is the notes the
details they do matter they may matter
very much you can't write the code
unless you know the syntax the code
won't compile it won't run however what
is far more important and then the names
of the arguments that get pass to exit
or the specific fashion in which
different numeric underscore methods get
dispatched whether you do our ad or or
ad depending on which is the most
derived class all of those details are
actually secondary to a core conceptual
understanding of what these feature mean
what these features mean
so what I can tell you as the real
lessons from this session or as follows
Python is a language orientated around
protocols there's some behavior some
syntax some bytecode or some top-level
function and there's a way for you to
tell Python how to implement that on an
arbitrary object the underscore methods
that exact correspondence is usually
guessable but if you can't guess it
Google Python data model and you'll find
all the different methods and all the
caveats of their use Python is a very
simple simplistic language in terms of
his execution model code runs from top
to bottom and things which would not be
executable statements in other languages
like class statements and function
definitions or generate definitions are
actually executable code in Python
because they're executable code not only
can you do things like hook into them
but you can also do things like define
functions within functions based off of
runtime data define classes within
functions based off of some runtime
information you have how these impact
specific features metaclasses metaclass
is merely some hook in a class
construction process because classes are
constructed at runtime you can hook code
in there and be
you can hook into the creation of
subclasses you can ask the subclass
certain questions like do you have these
methods implemented implemented that's
what they do that's the mechanism but
the meeting behind it is quite simple
you have library code and user code when
you sit on the library author side how
do you make sure the users don't screw
up how do you enforce a good straight
from the library code to the user code
well all that it takes is some way talk
into the process of how user code user
classes are instantiated that's merely
with the meta classes you find that
place where you add that hook you add
the check that you want Oh make sure
that you have the bar method implemented
and you solve the problem in fact in the
Python standard library there are
regularize solutions to problems like
that in collections of ABC there is an
ABC meta class it allows you to use
decorators to mark certain methods and
abstract methods so you don't have to
write the metaclass yourself and you can
think this is a pattern of what the meta
class is doing in fact almost every
example of a meta class that you'll see
will be this pattern of some base class
and some derived class the base class
trying to enforce the constraint on the
derived class it's almost every pattern
of the meta class that you'll see where
that meta classes are justified of
course you can misuse them to do all
sorts of crazy things you can use them
in places where it doesn't make any
sense but in the justified uses of the
metaclass
that's what it's all about for the
decorator it really incidentally that
interesting just a little bit of syntax
to allow you to write one line of code a
little bit nicer to take one line of
code that you write after your function
definition and put it above your
function definition when it hooks into
this idea in Python that everything gets
clear at runtime so that when you
combine that with the ability to define
functions within functions you can use
this in order to wrap sets of functions
with some before and after behavior if
you're been around long enough you might
think you might recall this was the
whole aspect orientated idea but the
idea that can I take a function and wrap
it with some behavior such as timing you
know capturing the time before capture
the time after or doing things like
authentication or logging anything where
you don't have to go it's
the function itself you just wrap the
behavior around it generators are merely
a way to take a single computation that
would otherwise run eagerly from the
insert from the injection of its
parameters to the final computation and
interleaving with other code by adding
yield points where you can yield the
temp the intermediate result values or
one small piece of the computation and
also yield control back to the caller
in that vein you can think of a
generator as being a way to take one
long piece of one long computation and
break it up in small parts where the
computation can run a small sub sub unit
of that computation but your user click
and step in and do whatever it wants
maybe it will use a partial value or use
one of the first return values if you're
returning a sequence of return values
you might use the each of the individual
values and in that fashion you can have
greater control over how much of that
how much of that computation actually
runs do you run it all the way to
completion or do need to run it to gab
the first five values you need you also
have greater control over how much
memory is used because the generator can
just yield the value back to you and you
can choose which of those return values
you want to keep which of the do you
want to throw away context managers are
merely some structure for allowing you
to tie two actions together a set up
action and a teardown action and make
sure they always happen in concordance
with each other if the set up action
occurs make sure that teardown action
occurs even if some error happens in the
middle now when you think about these
features and you realize they're related
but mostly orthogonal you can combine
them in interesting ways like you see in
this example here where you have a
decorator a context manager and a
generator all coexisting and serving
exactly it's one purpose as I said at
the very beginning the syntax doesn't
matter the details won't matter until
you need to use them what I want to
leave you with especially since a lot of
you are not already very fluent Python
programmers I want to leave you with
this idea remember what these features
are about remember what they're for
that's something that you should be able
to remember longer than the exact
details of the syntax or even
to details in fact the implementation
details the details on syntax will
change over time some of the flaws of
the ability ssin make it fixed other
details will be fixed another fashion
but the core meaning behind these is
something that will last and will guide
you towards writing expert level Python
code far better than memorizing just a
bunch of features ever will so that's my
presentation I hope you enjoyed it thank
you very much for being a part of it any
questions in the back a little louder
please
yeah and can I use like when I use yield
it basically continues to do the earlier
processing yes so so the idea is what
you've what you've immediately jumped on
is this idea that you can interleave
what you've I think it jumped on to is
the idea that well while I'm well I've
returned control back to the calling
context can I have the original context
keep keep working believe look a genetic
is kind of sit in the background and do
some work and then by the time I go back
to the generator I can go and ask it for
some value it doesn't have to do
anything because it's already in the
background done that well yes you can
you could have the generator start its
own thread and maybe do things in its
own thread that's entirely possible and
that wouldn't be part of the generator
syntax itself the generator itself is
not intended for interleaving in a
concurrency mindset and so where you see
generators used as part of this broader
idea of concurrency and Python is that
the generator mechanism and its syntax
have been further refining the Python
three six to this asynchronous
co-routine syntax there are many reasons
why strictly simultaneous running
Python code is something that has been
avoided for a very long time in Python
you must have heard of the global
interpreter lock of the limitations of
global interpreter lock accepting that
is a limitation the approaches that
people take in concurrency in Python
when they mean single in process
concurrency are typically either threads
and they ignore the global interpreter
lock or they just allow for strict
interleaving of code where you know it's
all single process so it's all single
threaded one thread one one greenlit
sleeps while the other one runs and you
don't have strictly concurrently running
greenland's that's closer to your answer
which is generally no the generator is
not for this kind of multi-threaded
equivalent approach it really is for
this one runs and this one runs and this
one runs this runs and that's considered
to be the preferred approach for
concurrency in Python where the
concurrency is i/o bound click
yeah
so you're referring to the runtime
chicks versus otherwise yeah so what
would be the other one would be the
point in time the other acids or
validations would happen so the problem
is runtime checks require you to have
the code deployed in a runtime apart so
you'll never know the problem until you
hit that exact code pad the whole point
of this is can we any sooner that when
it hits that code path in deployment in
a deployed environment catch the earth
any kind of run because Python doesn't
have a very strong compiler has a very
small very that compiler doesn't really
do a lot it's going to be very difficult
however what we can think of is that
module import time is an equivalent to
compile time and Python so just being
able to import a module it's something
that we can do before we hit the run
time compile context we can do it at our
laptop and if the module imports
normally then we can say ok this code
will be safe in production all of the
checks that we looked at there or checks
we can run by just sitting at our laptop
importing all of our modules if it
worked
we'd say good to go another thing that
we could do is maybe run a unit test
suite but that might be one level deeper
than these checks because you can think
the unit test suite is going to take a
lot longer to run and it might have some
mocking of data and moving things around
so we might have is some checks in the
file itself import everything ok good to
go then run our unit tests ok good to go
deploy to production and then hope that
somebody's online who knows how to solve
the problem when something breaks quick
follow one the unit subclasses they're
still run by motors it's they're all
they're all they're minute subclass is a
runtime check but everything that runs
at the module level is run at runtime
it's just that there are different
runtime scopes in Python so in its
subclass we'll operate in the same
fashion as the metaclass it'll merely
just another place that you can hook
into the initialization of a subclass
and you have to look into the details I
thought it took different arguments than
it does you'll have to look into the
details to see what arguments it takes
and how you actually use it for the for
this purpose there's a lot of these
details of these features unless you're
really hopeful you're never you're not
somebody who's constantly using them and
once you're constantly using them the
details are things that are easy to
forget but if you know where to look or
you know what to look for those are
details that you can very quickly pick
up and frankly and it's the questions
only been around since 3.6 a lot of
these details do change over time but
the core models the core mental models
have not changed since these features
were first introduced even the extension
of generators for co-routines
and for asynchronous programming the
core mental models behind and haven't
really changed since they were first
introduced in Python 2 6 2 whatever any
last questions ok well I hope you
enjoyed the session thank you very much